en football un nouveau venu c'est tout
un programme derrière ce nom 13 heures
les jeunes avec marius trésor qui le
nouveau venu de l'équipe de france que
je vous propose quand même de regarder
maintenant sur notre tableau cette
équipe est composée comme vous le voyez
finalement bosquier jouera bien rien
centrale mais avec une semelle en zinc
dans sa chaussure pour épargner un
orteil blessés au centre de l'attaqué
georges boulogne existe encore hésite
encore entre le duo révelli laich et
celui composé de révéler et de béryte
décision ce soit à ce sujet enfin il
faut remarquer la présence de marius
trésor au poste d'arrière gauche trésor
qui vient de la guadeloupe qui joue dans
les rangs de l'équipe d'ajaccio depuis
69 13 heures il faut le signaler et
surtout le premier joueur de couleur
depuis 1964 avec charles alfred qui va
jouer dans l'équipe de france se
présente lui-même maintenant au micro de
jean-pierre drax cette halle de la boit
de l'eau g j'aurais 22 ans le 15 janvier
72 c'est un commando accord survenu en
france par l'intermédiaire d'un
guadeloupéen qui s'appelle ou cpmb
autour du travail à beaucoup plan
professionnel
celui qui un jour m'a envoyé une lettre
en me disant si je voulais tenter ma
chance on en france je lui ai dit oui il
m'a mis en contact avec les dirigeants
d'ajaccio et de là est survenu mais
j'étais venu pour jouer à 60 parce que
c'est cette place pourrait jouer chez
moi
julian avant-centre à ce moment là je
vois que j'étais venu pour jouer à
droite à ajaccio le sud ouest et deux
mois ensuite j'ai demandé à l'entraîneur
qui était monsieur lui aussi avait pas
moyen de les changer de place
il m'a dit oui et many as encore que de
la sympathie des parties vous préférez
jouer en défense ou en attaque
je préfère jouer en défense parce que
c'est pour me plaît beaucoup
à quand remontent vos débuts en football
je joue au football depuis le plus petit
jeu connu un autre mis au point ces
j'avais 12 ans en la personne de
monsieur bernier qui était de passage un
goût de georges boulogne un nouveau
promu dans le club france c'est jules
marius trésor qu'est ce qui vous a fait
le sélectionner france que chez eux
c'est un défenseur de classe comme jeune
encore et a besoin de s'affirmer mais
promet beaucoup
je suis très content ou housse est entré
tout le monde m'a les dizaines de moyens
je ne pensais pas entrer c'est à la fin
de la fin du match aller je pense à lui
tous cas c'était pour les matchs photo
pour moi c'est un peu de plaisir